I love my grandma loved her very much my
grandma taught me about a lot taught me
what religion is tell me everything you
can know about religion one quick story
I'll tell you now when I graduated from
high school when I graduated high school
my grandma came to me gave me a big hug
said Anthony I'm so proud of you you're
my first grandchild to get to go to
college what can I do for you what can I
give you before you go to college I said
honestly grandma all I need from you is
money yeah I know you guys have never
been but college is expensive and my
grandma said okay Anthony I understand
so a couple months go by it's the end of
the summer I'm packing up my dad's car
getting ready to go to school and my
grandma walks up says Anthony here
before you leave take this and she
handed me a brand new Bible King James
Version and I said thanks grandma that's
exactly what we talked about
[Applause]
we've got in the car and I went off of
school a couple of weeks go by I'm
hanging out in my dorm room
having a good time on the phone rings
it's my grandma
cuz Anthony just calling to see how
college is going said grandma college is
the best I'm having the time of my life
but to be honest I'm already starting to
run low on money and I could use a
little bit like we talked about she said
okay Anthony will let me ask you this
have you been reading your Bible and I
said totally grandma I'm on chapter 4
[Music]
she's hit okay Anthony well then I guess
I'll talk to you later
hung up the phone a couple of months go
by now I'm really starting to struggle
financially we have to drop out of
school if I don't get some money so I
called my grandma in a panic I said
grandma please it's Anthony I'm having
the time of my life in college I love it
here but if I want to graduate and I do
I need you to send me some money like we
talked about
you should why Anthony let me ask you
this have you been reading your Bible
and I said yes grandma I wish it was
longer
she said okay Anthony well then I guess
I'll talk to you later finally at the
end of the school year
I've got straight A's but I'm dropping
out of college because I have no more
money left and I'm furious I'm close to
tears cleaning out my dorm room when the
phone rings it's my grandma which is
Anthony hurt you're dropping out of
school today how come and I said you
know goddamn well how come grandma
cuz you wouldn't give me any money
she said well Anthony let me ask you
this did you read your Bible and I just
hung up the phone I was so pissed off
took everything out of that room last
thing I took off the shelf the last
thing I took out of that room was that
Bible my grandma givin me took it off
the shelf held it in my hands and for
the first time I actually opened it up
and right there on the very first page
and my grandmother's handwriting it said
[__] you
the TV is all screwed or any kids here I
mean little kids and the life people
bringing little kids down here how are
you man how thorough you're gonna be
[__] up when you leave
yeah what's a dick what is that
how old are they do right there Oh y'all
[__] up now what the [__] I would be
going like this okay you know that [__]
right
no I be saying how addicted this big
[Applause]
kids gonna be waking up like this honey
gross picture come in to get me mama
I'm gonna tell you a little joke y'all
go tell in school all right it's cuz
I've been telling this dirty stuff okay
hit little joke for y'all y'all can
listen to it too but I know lots of time
people see my show then go to work and
try to tell my AK and [__] my jokes up
on the job if she let me sit and then he
said Cooney Google
and a GI Joe up his ass hey hey I'm mr.
t I'll rip your [__] off with my ass
and do be standing on yeah that's very
funny [__]
it's a joke that you can tell down at
school when school starts everybody be
quiet now you listening guys a bear and
a rabbit but taking a [__] in the woods
the bear turns to rap and says excuse me
you have problems with [__] sticking to
your fur and the rabbit says no so the
bear wiped his ass with the rabbit
I talked to a lot of people before I got
engaged you know and I heard this
expression about whether or not you
should get married
this is an old expression people say
this they say why buy the cow when you
can get the milk for free you ever heard
that before
it's a bananas insulting expression to
an entire gender but also it makes no
sense why buy the cow when you can get
the milk for free
you're not allowed to milk a cow that
you don't own that's not even a
situation
was that a problem at one point like in
the dairy community was that happening
like a hundred years ago in some village
some Dutch prick was sneaking in at
night being like haha take your milk and
the farmer was like one of them this is
your cow now and he was like nah no
proof of purchase and he ran off into
the night that sounded Dutch right you
know what that you know what that
expression means it means why would you
marry a woman if she's already having
sex with you which has nothing to do
with what relationships are even like
anymore now it's like why buy the cow
question mark
maybe because every day the Kyle asks
you when you're gonna buy it and you
live in a really small apartment with
the cow so you can't avoid that question
at all and also the cow is way better at
arguing than you are and the cow grew up
in a family that knows how to argue why
buy the cow question mark
maybe because every time another cow
gets bought you have to go to the sale
and
you have to sit next to your cow at the
sale and your cow looks over you the
entire time like
and does not enjoy the sale at all even
though she's the one that wanted to go
to the sale
and she's especially mad because that
farmer in cow met like eight months
after you guys met why buy the cow well
let's be real here you're very lucky to
have the cow that you do have their
roping in cows and getting milk out of
them was never anything you were known
for John by the most liberal of
estimates there have been about eight
cows total several um Milt and a lot of
people think that you like Bulls and if
you just thought they assumed it when
you search your name the third thing to
come up is like john mulaney bull
question mark and if you just bought the
cow nobody would say that anymore
they'll still say it because there are
those guys who they buy a cow and then
on the side total Matador but but for
real Chicago why buy the cow let's be
real why buy the cow because you love
her you really do and yeah yeah sure
she's a bossy little Q but
she takes care of you and you don't want
to be some old man stumbling around like
hey you seen any loose milk so one time
I'm flying into Albany New York okay
a city that nobody really goes to so I'm
on a smaller plane and everything's
going great all of a sudden out of
nowhere we hit this turbulence and it
stops and everybody looks around like
laughing nervously like oh all of a
sudden it comes back with App Engine you
can literally hear like the metal the
planes made out like all of a sudden
this dude like three rows back starts
making like these [__] noises like
look look
I'm not gonna lie I have never been so
[__] scared in my entire life who
that noise is acceptable out of a female
or a child
turn around and see a 37 year old
mustachioed males
good the hair was standing up on my arms
I'm praying to a higher power I don't
even believe in this [__] I just wish I
had the balls to turn around be like
dude but you shut the [__] up Jesus
Christ being man push it down push it
down deny your feelings act like you
have answers do some man [__] right now
who's the man [__]
you think I'm not up here thinking I am
but how does that help us for me to join
you and turn this fuselage into a
haunted house you know you know what
kills me what absolutely kills me is
some woman is gonna fall in love with
this guy marry him and make half [__]
kits
and you know what we become weaker as a
species
you know you have your bad thoughts
hopefully you only do good things
everybody has a competition in their
brain of good thoughts and bad thoughts
hopefully they way the good thoughts
wind for me I always have both I have
like the thing I believe the good thing
that's the thing I believe and then
there's this thing and I don't believe
it but it is there it's always this
thing and then this thing it's become a
category in my brain that I call of
course but maybe I'll give you an
example okay like of course of course
children who have nut allergies need to
be protected of course we have to
segregate their food from nuts have
their medication available at all times
and anybody who manufactures or serves
food needs to be aware of deadly nut
allergies of course but maybe maybe if
touching and that kills you you're
supposed to die
of course not of course not of course
not Jesus I have a nephew who has that
I'd be devastated if something happen to
him but maybe if we all just do this for
one year were done with nut allergies
forever it's not of course if you're
fighting for your country and you get
shot or hurt it's a terrible tragedy of
course but maybe maybe if you pick up a
gun and go to another country and you
get shot it's not that weird maybe if
you get shot by the dude you were just
shooting at it's a tiny bit your fault
[Applause]
of course of course slavery is the worst
thing that ever
[Applause]
listen listen you all clapped for dead
kids with a nuts from nuts you applauded
so you're in this with me now you
understand you don't get to cherry-pick
[Applause]
of course of course slavery is the worst
thing that ever happened of course it is
every time it's happened
black people in America Jews in Egypt
every time a whole race of people has
been enslaved it's a terrible horrible
thing of course but maybe maybe every
incredible human achievement in the
history was done with slaves every
single thing where you go how did they
build those pyramids they just threw
human death and suffering at them until
they were finished how did we traverse
the nation with a railroad so quickly we
just threw Chinese people in caves and
blew them up and then give a [__] what
happened to them there's no end to what
you can do when you don't get a [__]
about particular people you can do
anything
that's where human greatness comes from
is that we're shitty people that we
[__] others over even today how do we
have this amazing micro technology
because the factory were they're making
these they jump off the [__] roof
because it's a nightmare in there you
really have a choice you could have
candles and horses and be a little
kinder to each other or let someone
suffer in measurably far away just so
you can leave a mean comment on YouTube
while you're taking a [__]